fight sky hook a moment ago
[Music]
and green throws it out of bounds well
the warriors were four on five there
something happened with Gary Payton he's
going to the locker room now but he just
stopped on this and there was no one
over there
Peyton left the floor he ran through the
tunnel into the locker room while that
sequence was going on and certainly
Draymond Green in the free-flow offense
You're Expecting individuals in certain
spots and nobody was there
green he thought Phil handy was open and
feeling his day was a great shooter Phil
should have stepped he said great pass
that's what Phil said great pass
[Applause]